THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE AND
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEES MET WITH
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL ON
FISA ABUSE RECORDS, WOULD WE
KNOW?
>> THE MEETING AFTER CHAIRMAN
NUNEZ ISSUED A SUBPOENA ABOUT
ALLEGED SURVEILLANCE ABUSE
DURING THE 2016 ELECTION.
CHAIRMAN NUNEZ AND GAUDI MET
WITH ROD ROSENSTEIN AS WELL AS
FBI AND INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS.
A FULL YEAR FAMILIAR, RELATED TO
A INTELLIGENCE SOURCE ARE NOT AS
SIGNIFICANT AS THE DOSSIER YOU B
SIGNIFICANT AS THE DOSSIER YOU Y
SIGNIFICANT AS THE DOSSIER YOU T
SIGNIFICANT AS THE DOSSIER YOU E
SIGNIFICANT AS THE DOSSIER YOU F
SIGNIFICANT AS THE DOSSIER YOU I
SIGNIFICANT AS THE DOSSIER YOU T
SIGNIFICANT AS THE DOSSIER YOU O
SIGNIFICANT AS THE DOSSIER YOU S
SIGNIFICANT AS THE DOSSIER YOU R
SIGNIFICANT AS THE DOSSIER YOU E
SIGNIFICANT AS THE DOSSIER YOU I
SIGNIFICANT AS THE DOSSIER YOU
SIGNIFICANT AS THE DOSSIER YOU A
CAMPAIGN AIDE.
IT WAS GNC AND CLINTON CAMPAIGN
FUNDED OPPOSITION RESEARCH.
THE CHAIRMAN HAVE TO HOUSE
SPEAKERS BACKING.
>> IT IS COMPLETELY WITHIN THE
SCOPE OF THE INVESTIGATION THAT
HAS BEEN ONGOING FOR A WHILE
WITH THE FLIES OUT, ACTUALLY
THINK THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE BEEN
ANSWERED A WHILE AGO.
>> IN A STATEMENT AFTER THE
MEETING, THE CHAIRMAN SAID THAT
THE DIALOGUE WILL CONTINUE NEXT
WEEK, THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
SAID THAT THEY WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON A
RESOLUTION AND COMPLETE THE
REQUEST.
>> Bret: ON THOSE MICHAEL
COHEN RECORDS, THEIR LEGAL
MANEUVERS WITH THE BANK RECORDS?
>> AND COURT FILINGS, THE LEGAL
TEAM SAYS THAT SOME RECORDS
BELONG TO OTHER MICHAEL COHEN'S
ACCUSE OF MAKING "TOO NUMEROUS
PUBLIC AND AN APPARENT ATTEMPT
TO PREJUDICE AND DISCREDIT TO
MR. COHEN, IT IS SOMEHOW
OBTAINING RANDOM BANK RECORDS
AND OBTAINING THEM FOR THE
ACCURACY IS EXTREMELY TROUBLING
FOR THE COURT AND THE PUBLIC.
ON TWITTER, HE RESPONDED THAT
THE COHEN FINDINGS ARE BASELESS
AND HE ACCUSES THE TEAM OF
CONCEDING THE RECEIPTS OF A HALF
A MILLION DOLLARS FROM THOSE
WITH RUSSIA TIES, THE COMPANY
SAID THAT IT OWNED AND
CONTROLLED BY AMERICANS, THE
TREASURY IMPORTANT WITH AN